le versailles handball club s'est fait
peur ce dimanche 26 mars à domicile en
tête du début à la fin de la rencontre
les bleus et roses ont réussi à
s'extirper du piège tendu par le dernier
du classement draveil pour l'emporter 29
à 27 ans leur gymnase mon bon on a mené
tout le match on mérite de cette
victoire mais on s'est fait peur c'est
pour ça que je dis soulagée
mené de cinq buts à quatre minutes de la
fin on gagne que 2 guillemets mais bon
je vais aussi des matchs où cela on peut
les perdre ou faire match nul est
finalement la gagner donc l'essentiel
est fait et je félicite les gars pour la
victoire notre apport offensif était bon
mais ensuite on s'est un peu endormi sur
nos lauriers on peut un peu cru que
c'était parce que déjà fait à cinq
minutes de la fin alors qu'on aurait pu
on aurait dû continuer continuer leur
maître en défi physique aux oiseaux
cette performance est une véritable
bouffée d'oxygène pour les versailles et
au classement les hommes de la cité
royale reste 6e du championnat mais
accentuent leur avance sur le premier
relégable y compte désormais trois
points de plus que val de seine on va
pouvoir grignoter cette cinquième place
qui je pense est beaucoup plus à la
hauteur de notre équipe mais c'est loin
d'être fait choper pas de le dire il
faut pour cela gagner a prioritairement
les trois prochains a dit dans un
premier temps et je vous dirai à mon
avis les trois d'après aussi encore donc
pour l'instant on pense on et assureront
le maintien c'est à dire les trois
prochains matches les versaillais se
rendront ce samedi 1er avril sur le
terrain de saint-ouen-l'aumône un autre
concurrent direct dans la course au
maintien
[Applaudissements]